[Musique]
la reine réagi après l'interview de
mégane et harry communiqué publié hier
par buckingham palace ils auront il aura
fallu attendre un jour et demi c'est pas
long mais en même temps vous allez voir
le communiqué est assez court 1 3 lignes
on y lit que toute la famille est très
attristé d'apprendre à quel point ces
dernières années ont été difficiles pour
arié méga une bête ignames palace qui
précise que les souvenirs peuvent varier
façon de répondre directement aux
accusations de racisme
nous sommes fatigués des clash des
rebondissements des tensions c'est plus
une famille royale ce sont des candidats
de télé réalité
à ce rythme là la prochaine saison de
the crowd sera diffusée sur w9
et vous savez quoi on a déjà le
générique
[Musique]
ok sur l'absolue les temps et pas de
coups bas et via sa propre émission et
quitte sa mission je suis devant skyrock
et gérald et la guerre pour gad elmaleh
et mentale comme cette aventure est
intervenu pendant monsieur atangana
kouna qu'est ce qui se passe que ce soit
ici alors nous souvient musique est pas
content
c'est la mer
si je vous
monsieur qui est pas content c'était les
problèmes
s'amuser alors là régis vous êtes loin
quand même
vous êtes grands c'est vrai vous pouvez
vous rapprocher je le droit
oui oui vous avez le droit quand même
c'est vrai que jusque là voilà cette
image surprenante en thaïlande où le
premier ministre vous le voyez à
asperger des journalistes avec du spray
hydroalcoolique
c'est une question en conférence de
presse sur les postes vacants au sein de
son cabinet qui a hérité donc le premier
ministre thaïlandaise c'est n'importe
quoi mais très étrange cela fait trois
jours que cette limaces de mer c'est
décapité et la tête continuent à vivre
la scène est digne d'un film d'horreur
s'amuse la scientifique japonaise à
l'origine de cette étonnante découverte
et il y encore plus impressionnant en
moins d'un mois le mollusque parvient à
régénérer tout son corps organe compris
avec un coeur qui bat à nouveau je suis
très content d'aller faire la danse
orientale
maintenant j'ai des formes il faut faire
bouger tout en plastique c'est sûr qu'à
l'époque que j'aurais fait bouger du
toit si aujourd'hui tout le monde
connaît madame lisa c'est parce que
cette tenancière de bordel a tout
compris de la com alors que dans la
prostitution au règne la loi du silence
lisa a toujours choisi d'ouvrir grand la
bouche je travaille
jean à madame madame madame warda
travail à bout ou leur quête pour départ
il ya un an c'est vrai que les
télétravailleurs du monde entier
découvrait zoom 7 applications de
visioconférence certes pratique a l'air
de lakovic 19 mai qui peut provoquer
chez certains de la fatigue du stress
même des maux de tête alors tout cela
était jusqu'ici une sensation mais cela
vient d'être prouvé scientifiquement par
les universitaires de stanford
bernard sabbah dont c'est l'anniversaire
[Musique]
souhaitons lui bonne anniversaire sur
twitter pourquoi pas sur le hashtag cpv
à aulas bernard d'amitié ça fait plaisir
oui ça c'est vous qui le dites
bon c'est vrai je peux pas lier d'amitié
il ya + 35 ans il ya eu quatre mois
pouvoir en gros plan l'image de son
collègue parfois des inconnus qui
débarque comme ça dans son espace intime
et bien amplifie le stress davantage que
dans des réunions physiques il parle
même de surcharge non verbale
il évoque aussi ce réflexe d'auto
évaluation que l'on peut avoir en étant
captivé par sa propre image dans les
petites vignettes cars déjà soit fin et
jason ne tient pas c'est quoi c'est
cindy lo pid le sosie approximative de
cyndi lauper
non mais c'est je ne connais pas en fait
c'est pas l'air c'est pas le grand c'est
pas le bonheur ça j'ai pas envie de
parler en fait non il savouré cette
belle ambiance
c'est ça ça réchauffe on n'a pas besoin
d'un duvet vous comprenez d'un plaid
quand on a autant d'affection comme ces
élus dont nous alors elle c'est tout ou
rien mais c'est le feu sous la glace
vous savez bien c'est son côté matt
kelly
voilà exactement alex oui je veux tu
être mon compagnon de table aujourd'hui
oui je le veux
deux doigts s'il vous plaît dis-donc
annie qu'est ce qui vous arrive
elle s'est rendue compte en le disant tu
as entre 7 et jean-marc j'ai compté 8
avec avaleuse où ils le savent surtout
la vie nantes
j'ai vu une fille on m'avait prévenu
qu'il y avait des filles bois de
boulogne et du coup ils étaient assis
sur un banc et je suis allé la voir j'ai
dit bonjour je me présente je suis le
père jean-philippe de la paroisse d'à
côté là
et puis un peu les pieds à la tête
ça me dit mais 50 euros comme tout le
monde mais qui partent à vide mais de
l'essence bah j'ai confondu les jauges
tu déconnes
non mais j'ai cru que c'était le
thermomètre fut celle du moteur sa
première fois qu'on l'a fait c'est là
aulas car cela